see you never know what you'll find out
there Ginny Weasley is a major character
in the Harry Potter books but she gets
the short end of the stick in the movies
she's even got a dark side just like
Harry keep watching to find out 10 facts
about the youngest Weasley that will
change how you watch all the movies if
you never read the books you might not
understand just how popular Ginny
Weasley was her popularity is completely
glossed over in the movies but it's a
pretty important plot point for her
character in the series in the sixth
book Gary has realized that he has
feelings for Ginny however she's super
popular which makes it hard for Harry to
make a move Ginny has it all she's
really pretty and popular with boys
she's considered cool among the girls
she's smart but she's not a know-it-all
like Hermione and she is an important
member of the Gryffindor Quidditch team
her popularity is also important for
Ron's character development
he's never been cool he's always lived
in his older brothers shadows bill and
Charlie were super popular
everyone likes Fred and George because
of their pranks Percy wasn't liked but
he was the top of his class
Ron feels very inadequate and having a
popular little sister makes it worse
some fans think that her popularity came
out of nowhere but that's not entirely
true the books are from Harry's
perspective and he can be pretty
oblivious plus she was a grade lower
than him actually he's sort of screamed
it was a bit frightening when it comes
to her love life
Ginny matures really quickly in the
books we just don't get to see much of
that in the movies at all her first Dane
is to the Yule Ball as a third year she
wasn't automatically allowed to go to
the dancing Goblet of Fire the winter
party that was meant to celebrate the
Triwizard Tournament was only for fourth
years enough but she could go if she was
invited and Neville asked her to go it
was the start of a good friendship with
Neville by Ginny's fourth year she is
actively dating and Ron has a huge issue
with it he quickly crosses the line from
concerned sibling to overprotective
brother but don't expect me to be
grateful just because now is another
damn thing we've both
Jeanne's first serious relationship was
with michael corner he's a ravenclaw and
they bond over their love of Quidditch
but we don't see a lot of Michael in the
books he's a little one-dimensional
later on
Ginny starts dating Harry and Ron's
roommate Dean Thomas it's suggested that
they have a pretty serious relationship
and that they make out all the time
she totally goes off on Ron for being
immature about things like that it seems
silly doesn't it wedding given
everything that's going on she may have
a healthy dating life but Ginny isn't
all butterflies and rainbows the fiery
Gryffindor has an angry streak and you
do not want to be on Ginny's bad side
she doesn't just have a temper though
she's actually quite skilled with some
brutal spells apparently she's the best
I casted me bad bogey hex this dangerous
hex is left out of the movies but it's
such a crucial part of her character the
bad bogey X makes bats fly out of
people's noses when this spell is cast
on non wizards it can be fatal Ginny
cast the spell on Draco Malfoy and
Delores on bridges office it allows her
and the rest of the gang to get away so
they can head to the Department of
mysteries in book 6 she cast the spell
out Zacharias Smith when he annoys her
one too many times her use of the spell
is so great that Professor Slughorn
invites her to join his slug Club talk
about a teacher who is a bad influence
later in life Ginny even teaches this
hex - the auras
[Music]
Harry Potter might have been the
youngest seeker in Hogwarts history and
he was really great at that position but
he wasn't the best Gryffindor Quidditch
player during his time that honor goes
to Ginny Weasley
Umbridge gave Harry a lifetime ban from
Quidditch my office
Ginny tried out for his position and
became the new seeker she was great at
it although she said Harry was better
but she helped to lead the Gryffindor
team to victory once Harry was back she
got to pursue her first love Ginny much
preferred playing chaser and she was
excellent at it a chaser is the one who
scores points with the Quaffle by
throwing them through the hoops she
tried out for the role when Harry became
captain she scored a ton of points
during that season because of her
Gryffindor won the Quidditch Cup in
half-blood Prince her skills at chaser
were so great that she eventually became
a professional player Ginny is such a
strong character in the later books that
it's easy to forget her dark history
during her first year at Hogwarts she
was extremely lonely she wrote about
being poor and having secondhand robes
she talked about how her brother's
always teased her she also had a huge
crush on Harry but was too shy to say
anything before she starts school Lucius
Malfoy slips Tom Riddle's diary into her
cauldron she starts writing all of her
feelings in this diary but the Diary is
possessed by the soul of Tom Riddle aka
Lord Voldemort he starts to possess her
she blacks out a lot because he makes
her carry out various attacks she's the
one who opens the Chamber of Secrets but
somehow no one notices she's a really
smart girl though she eventually
realizes that the diary is causing all
her problems and tries to get rid of it
but the diary reappeared and riddle
possessed her again
Harry had to save her from the Chamber
of Secrets this definitely changed Ginny
and she became a much stronger character
afterward it was me I swear I didn't
mean to
it'll make me
Ginny can seem a little too perfect at
times she's popular and pretty she's
smart and great at magic and she's a
Quidditch star but she's got some major
flaws one of those is her jealousy
Harry's first love interest was Cho
Chang I've never been able to spend
anything and Jenny couldn't stand her
throughout order of the Phoenix Ginny is
really dismissive of Cho but she and Cho
have a lot in common
they're both great at Quidditch and are
smart and popular she's even caddy in
the middle of a battle Cho offers to
take Harry to the ravenclaw common room
during the Battle of Hogwarts to see the
diadem Ginny steps in and demands that
Luna take him instead it's a weird time
to be jealous Ginny he's trying to save
the world he's not gonna go make out
with Cho but it's good that Ginny isn't
perfect her flaws make her more
interesting keep watching to find out
how Ginny's dreams came true Ginny is a
great friend to Hermione the two become
really close very early on
Hermione always shares Ginny's room at
the Burrow they can fight in each other
a lot but Ginny isn't always a nice
person to other girls she's the one who
introduces Harry to Luna she calls her
Luna Lovegood because luna is weird
[Music]
Luna thinks that they are much better
friends than that eventually the two
become better friends but Ginny is very
mean and dismissive of Luna early on she
comes across as a total mean girl when
she calls Luna Looney she's also really
mean to Fleur Delacour
who marries her brother bill girl is a
smart kind and talented witch but Ginny
hates her she nicknames her phlegm and
is really awful to her we aren't sure if
she's jealous because she doesn't want
her brother to get married but we are
sure of one thing
Ginny used to hate flow with a passion
bill takes his stakes on the wrong side
now my husband Joker
Jenny might be mean sometimes but she
also has a strong sense of justice she
is definitely a Gryffindor because she
is very brave she's one of the first
people to sign up for double doors army
in order of the Phoenix she isn't afraid
to break rules to learn how to fight and
she definitely isn't scared of Umbridge
in Deathly Hollows Ginny is one of the
resistance leaders among the students
she and Neville o the students who keep
everyone organized she's staying in the
secret room when Harry comes back to
Hogwarts to find the Horcruxes it's
clear that she's been standing up to
Snape in the other Death Eaters she
isn't as injured as some of the students
but she's been fighting back take my
hand
she's also determined to fight she's
supposed to stay hidden during the
battle because she's underaged even
though her whole family puts their wands
to good use she sneaks back into the
castle and the later battles Bellatrix
Lestrange directly
when we see Ginny in the epilogue she's
married to Harry and they have three
kids but Ginny doesn't just become a
housewife she has an amazing career
after she finishes Hogwarts she is
recruited by the Professional Quidditch
team the Holyhead harpies it's an all
women team and she becomes their top
chaser it's hard to become a
professional athlete but Ginny has what
it takes
after she plays pro Quidditch for a
while she changes careers she and Harry
had kids you can't she was christened oh
this whole thing happened takes your
choice into account so she wanted a less
risky job she starts writing for the
Daily Prophet the top Wizarding
newspaper she becomes the senior
Quidditch correspondent that's one
impressive job title everyone knows who
Ginny Weasley is because Quidditch is so
popular among the Wizarding community
she's so much more than just the wife of
Harry Potter she really does have a
dream career sorry I'm not usually late
lots of girls dream about meeting their
favorite celebrity and falling in love
but Ginny actually gets to do this she's
relatable because she is the ultimate
fangirl and she is living the dream when
she first meets Harry she can't even
speak to him she is completely obsessed
with him her first year at Hogwarts she
writes him a love poem which she has a
dwarf read to him it's pretty terrible
she compares his eyes to a toad she
never really stops being here he's
number one fan although she does have a
life outside of him wait I think when I
finally realized I read the book and you
saw whether where they went it comes to
love him for the person that he is not
just because he's famous and Harry
starts to feel the same way about her
she helps him a lot in later books
especially when he's obsessed with the
half-blood Prince she finally gets with
Harry after they win the Quidditch
championship in the sixth book and then
she gets to Miriam they have three
children together James
Albus and Lily it's a fangirls dream
what's your favorite Ginny Weasley
moment let us know in the comments below
thanks for watching subscribe to the
things to never miss another video and
don't forget to hit that like button
we'll catch you next time